With all the excitement surrounding the
2008 election,
it might be surprising to learn that
only 56 point nine percent of eligible
citizens a little over half the
population,
it turned out to vote that year.
That's pretty bad,
but at least it was a few points better
than 2012 and this kind of voter turnout
puts us pretty low on the list of
developed countries,
which is not something to be proud of,
but it also means that voter
mobilization efforts have the potential
to yield massive results.
I mean,
for example,
Romney only lost to Obama by 5 million
votes last time.
It's a pretty small number compared to
the $112 million still up for grabs and
get out the vote.
Campaigns come in a few different
varieties.
The most inane and probably the least
effective is that kind work.
Leonardo Dicaprio in a laundry list of
other celebrities command you to vote
from the TV.
I mean,
seriously,
after all this,
after this whole video,
if you're not going to vote,
I don't even know what the sad anymore.
Wow.
Leo,
that really hurts even self-aware and
comedic campaigns in this vein,
like the one just Sweden made earlier
this year like lead,
don't move the needle all that much
because they rely on old fashioned
techniques,
namely a handful of righteous messages
that include things like it's your
responsibility to vote for your voice,
won't be heard otherwise,
or it's historic and slash or really,
really close election.
The while,
these are all really good reasons to
vote.
They all operate under the assumption of
a behavioral theory called rational self
interest for decades and decades.
People assume that if social norms about
voting,
we're heavily reinforced like they are
in those ads,
then people would just comply to satisfy
their sense of civic duty.
Unfortunately,
when put to the test,
these techniques came up way short than
a landmark.
Two thousand eight paper from Gerber
Green and larimer extensive studies
found that theories based on rational
self interested behavior generally fail
to predict significant turnout.
This goes for celebrities talking to you
through the TV or online,
as well as phone banks,
direct mail,
or door to door canvasing.
The problem is that plenty of people
tell you they're going to vote,
but don't actually do so when the time
comes,
but behavioral research can offer us
some tricks to help study show for
example,
that if you ask people about their
specific plan,
ask them where they're voting or how
they're going to get there.
You could double or triple your
effectiveness.
Also,
campaigners often tell people that every
vote counts more when there's a low
turnout,
so their vote is extra important,
but the research shows that people are
more likely to vote if they think
there's going to be a high turnout.
In other words,
if everyone else is doing it too.
Okay,
but what if you really wanted to boost
the vote?
Is there anything that would motivate
people in a really big way?
Well,
let's go back to that paper from Gerber
Green and Larabar because I think it's
really fascinating what they did.
They basically conducted a large scale
field experiment where they mailed out
letters to four different groups of
people.
The first was a standard campaign mailer
that said,
do your civic duty vote basically like
those commercials who were looking at
the second inform people that they would
be confidentially studying voter turnout
for the election.
Now,
let me just pause here to say something
that you may not know in America,
everyone's voting record.
It's public.
Now,
don't freak out because you can't find
out who people voted for,
only if they voted or not.
In fact,
in the third meal or the researchers did
just that they mailed people their own
voting record from the past two
elections.
Looks like Robert Wayne wasn't able to
make it out there in 2004 and the fourth
mailer,
and this is where it gets really
interesting,
takes it one step further.
Not only did they send out people's
voting records,
but they also included the voting
records of their neighbor so that
everyone could see who voted and who
didn't.
Now,
while the turnout of the first group,
the group who got the regular mailer
raised,
one point eight percentage points,
turnout in the last group increased by
eight point one percentage points,
which is a huge increase and it makes
sense.
I wouldn't want to be the only one on my
block who didn't vote.
Now I'm not saying this is the right
thing to do.
It's probably not,
but imagine if facebook told you that it
was instituting a flair on your avatar
after the election based on the public
record that simply said,
voted something that you didn't have to
put up if you didn't want to,
but couldn't put up if you didn't vote
or imagine if it just put a big didn't
vote after someone's saying,
I bet you'd see a pretty significant
increase in voting across the board.
Now I realized that shaming people is
probably not the best motivator and
researchers found that this method did
receive a fair amount of backlash,
but it is interesting to think about
voter participation is something that
concerns all of us because only about
half of Americans vote every four years
and far fewer at local elections in
between.
I mean,
just imagine if the over 100 million
people who don't vote could be motivated
to do so.
The political landscape that everyone
seems to be so tired of could be totally
transformed,
but you know,
don't take it from me.
I mean,
seriously,
after all this,
after this whole video,
if you're not going to run,
I don't even know what to say to you
anymore.
There is a new nerve writer video every
Wednesdays.
Be in that box right there.
You know what?
Forget about this.
Can you see it as Florence,
Italy and it's the most beautiful thing
I've ever seen.
I'm here with my parents today,
Hon.
sorry.
The videos had been late.
I just spent so much here to Italy.
It's been so amazing.
Anyway,
I have to think squarespace for
sponsoring this video that makes leak
intuitive websites.
Um,
you sign up for a year,
you get a free domain
name@squarespace.com.
Offer Code nerdwriter.
You can get 10 percent off your first
purchase squarespace website.
But look at this amazing.